[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris weber member of the basketball
hall of fame class of 2021 former nba on
tnt analyst and uh friend of the show
good to have chris back on the program i
don't know did you see the zion
williamson dunk there chris and uh if
you did well what do you what do you
make of what zion is saying in that
video
well i think
even even at my worst i can
jump better than all you broke me uh
critics
so
i think he's just saying you know he's
back um it's so funny the internet i
thought the dunk was incredible
um
but a lot of people pointed out that he
was reaching or stretching and
barely got up over and i think that's
just the expectation he set when he's
usually looking inside the rim that
anything he does is not going to be good
enough because he's done that for us but
hopefully
and then he means he's held the use of
sports in context and to me
hope they wait till guys retired and may
come atop this or top that because
it's really hard to stay healthy and
it's really hard to have a great career
with health involved i think we take
that for granted with magic i'm sorry i
think we took that for granted with
lebron um when magic
really didn't even get those years so um
hopefully he's healthy and uh that's
what he's just yeah but it feels like
they're gonna shut him down he's not
gonna play and then he put it puts out
this video i can't i can't imagine the
pelicans are happy that he put that out
there that hey we're we're probably not
going to let him play
but hey look at what i can and almost
like he's saying i can play they don't
want me to play
now isn't this a new social media thing
a trip
because you're right you know because in
my mind i'm thinking wait a minute new
orleans has to put that out but you're
right he put that out and so yeah if i'm
the team um what type of message does
this send to
my
fans first and foremost i'll be trying
re-tanking it is he going to come back
you know with all the um the
hub of about him not contacting new
teammates is he a good teammate he's in
the gym by himself so yeah i think you
know as an athlete you really have to be
a great teammate of the organization in
the business of basketball you know if
you're on the same page and
this would seem to say they're not on
the same page so yeah i'm healthy enough
to do these crazy dunks that would have
won uh i can't play uh
i can't play tonight against sacramento
was gonna lose so yeah that's that's not
a great message you're in our bracket
challenge and i was curious who you
picked to win it all you being the proud
michigan uh fan there uh you picked
houston to win the national title chris
yeah it was houston against baylor so
obviously i don't know what i'm talking
about baylor's knocked out but i think i
got michigan getting to the game against
houston so at least i have us
going against uh what i thought was the
national championship wait wait did you
tell juwan howard that you were picking
houston to win the national championship
i can't hear my phone's breaking up
so
i gotta tell him that you picked houston
to win the national title
yeah but yeah but they beat us in triple
overtime with a bad call by the ref at
the end so make sure you let them know
okay that was that that's what happened
yeah but no i mean you know we weren't
supposed to be in a turn
uh um honestly
in my opinion and meaning that you know
i didn't know if we were going to be
have the favorite committee and once
they gave us that favor
you know those kids have a lot of heart
man um i only talked about this once but
when i really got to and be with them in
person it was just uh such an electric
feeling and
you know damn like when guys really
believe that's just the most part
because
when guys believe then that means you
don't have to preach extra guys make
sure you're in your group let's work
hard let's talk about the you know when
you're on that same page there's
something so specific
but
not necessarily oh they're going to win
a championship but more like man these
guys are going to remember this for the
rest of their life and they're going to
base a lot of principles on how to work
how to uh communicate how to be a great
teammate through district so i'm really
happy for joanne i'm happy for the team
um i'm happy for michigan fans although
what was it like to go in the locker
room with the team and give a pep talk
uh
it it
unexpected then like i know people may
think uh you know you had it all behind
the dance with juwan all this but really
i was just real i just soaked up
when i was going there like oh my god
i'm going back i get to see some friends
i haven't seen a long time and then you
know the uh equipment manager the same
equipment manager i had
jay smith uh he coached my brother
essentially he was my pink man's coach
there
he's back at the university so it was
just so great it was surreal and then
you know ray jackson had been
you know really been i don't sit down on
my side that's my boy he's been hitting
on my nerves like just passing you're
like let me go we're gonna do this and
he's such he's so making fun that when i
got in there and the first thing he says
is um you guys must be really good
because you got the black unicorn to
come out because it never comes off
like all these jokes were just it was
wait you're the you're the black unicorn
you're the black unicorn well
yeah i'm not not porzingis but he says i
never you know come out the house that
so it must have been but
in the middle of a speech in the team
you haven't seen it forever for that
jokes on you i mean it was just uh it
was it was really special there was a
lot of uh
a lot of happy feeling and and most of
the feeling was for winning that game i
mean that's what it got back to not
necessarily oh wait but you believe it
we talked about it was more like
he did a great coaching job great
addressing this in the second half i
can't keep watching these games because
i'm getting sick on the side it was uh
definitely was one of the best uh sport
experiences you know that i've had
especially since retirement he's a hall
of famer chris weber former uh member of
the fab five at michigan i know you're
doing stuff with collectibles and the
nft marketplace and you know follow me
on this you had the ill-fated timeout in
march madness
could you
how do you monetize could you monetize
your timeout in the uh national title
game
sure i'm sure um well truthfully i have
it
um i speak relations
uh i've been on this probably since the
day of the timeout
hold on hold on a second chris your
phone is sure kind of shorten out there
let's see if we can get a better
connection there uh can you hear me
chris
i can't sorry about that dan um so you
know you're doing stuff with nft
uh
and i i wonder and we've talked about
the timeout before you named your
foundation timeout so i didn't know is
that something that you
can monetize
um hopefully you care about that i'm
saying that yeah i've been monetizing
the time out very hard since the day i
called it i'm speaking in uh
so many corporations of so many people
and it's just about
handle your worst moment
um what do you do
how do you have accountability how do
you come back out of it how do you
encourage yourself
and then you know kind of the corporate
strategies how to be a good teammate
because i believe the best you know what
a great is when exactly it's great girl
you stay late you'll be a good teammate
you're empowered you're a good leader
communicate all those things and so
i've been doing that since then
hopefully helping a lot of people but
with this enough of coin electables what
we're doing um is we're bridging um the
from the digital world and i think many
companies out there are doing a
wonderful job however i'm lucky to be
with the first company that um has gone
public uh from nft and they believed in
me and we're going to really um with our
partnership really
engage the fans with experiences so
whereas yes i came out of town i'm sure
i have
the you call the timeout and choose the
you know i have everything i'm a i'm a
sports hoarder
so i've always kept my stuff but at the
same time i think what i'm trying to do
here is we're going to have wonderful
partnerships
um with agencies and companies that have
established relationships with athletes
and help bring them into the metaverse
and use it so i'm working with a lot of
different agencies and partnerships to
make sure that you know the experience i
understand in this that i get to other
athletes because the one good thing
about the another diverse you never get
old like i can still jump i might even
be able to do the zion dunk in the
metaverse um so uh just looking forward
to
looking forward to uh to engage with you
well it's great to talk to you again
chris and uh good luck to your
wolverines and uh certainly your houston
cougars as well winning the national
title
hey man i just picked that out blindly
but uh sorry for the for the uh terrible
uh line here i live on the farm but
thank you for always having me on dan i
really appreciate it that's a c webb
a member of the basketball hall of fame